martin boucher était infirmière depuis
sept ans à l'hôpital le gardeur bonsoir
madame boucher lanceurs messieurs le
gauche parce que vous avez plus
l'entente doit entendre des extraits de
sa conférence de presse vous êtes
vraiment celle à qui parler dit il avec
son parti vers le privé revenez s'il
vous plaît qu'est-ce que je peux faire
revenir parce qu'il ya des choses qui
ferait que vous reveniez vous
reviendriez opprimés au public
ben c'est sûr que au niveau des
conditions je pense que tout qu'est-ce
que l'offre le privé qui plus de
stabilité au plus haut niveau des
horaires au niveau de la vie familiale
où il ya aussi les temps supplémentaire
obligatoire que un enfant à l'hôpital
public que c'est juste par dessus les
dents ça revient toujours au début
c'était plus une fois de temps en temps
maintenant c'est déjà toutes les
semaines plusieurs fois par semaine
qu'on est obligé de rester donc on voit
qu'il ya vraiment un manque criant de
personnel donc déjà le faudrait qui
commence par aller chercher des jambes
c'est sûr que aller chercher des gens au
public
sage et les j'ai l'impression ça serait
pas assez parce que là on est vraiment
en manque et il ya plus de relève non
plus les gens ne veulent plus aller
serment dans ce métier parce que il ya
rien de positif qui sort du métier donc
on est plus de relève après bon
parce que un cercle vicieux vous êtes
consciente que plus il ya des
infirmières qui quêtent le public plus
pour celles qui restent on est obligé de
demander du temps supplémentaire
obligatoire parce que il y a des choses
à faire pimentent demont qu'est-ce qui
si j'augmente votre salaire de 20% de
30% pour retourner au public et skull la
question salariale pourrait vous faire
réfléchir
en fait deux bases des infirmières quand
qu'on ait décidé de devenir infirmières
s'étaient pas nécessairement pour le
salaire c'est plus par passion donc
c'est un récit confus parce que on aime
soit on aime le contact avec les gens
on le savait à l'avancé que c'est pas le
plus gros des salaires qu'on avait avant
même de commencer
ce métier donc si je pense au niveau de
la stabilité au niveau des comtés on
vous la surcharge de travail au niveau
de la sécurité au travail
si plus c'est ok vous la bouche et c'est
pas une question d'argent même si on
vous donnait beaucoup plus d'argent
c'est vraiment une question de
d'horaires de qualité de vie vous voulez
pas être prises à travailler jour et
nuit
sans savoir votre horaire pour les deux
trois quatre cinq prochains mois
ben c'est sûr que c'est pose une qualité
de travail c'est vraiment de base c'est
sûr qu'il ya certes eu vient avec mais
si on peut au moins nous offrir quelque
chose un horaire qui est stable donc pas
travailler jour soir nuit dans la même
semaine pour savoir quand on rentre si
on va retourner à la maison si je vais
être capable d'aller chercher ma fille à
la garderie parce que finalement une
guerre dont un césar n'est parfait qui
après huit heures de travail aux êtres
beaucoup d'ordres sa journée dans le
port comme on dit qu'il est fatigué mais
le mot juste avant de partir on dit je
suis désolée pour vous restez buteur de
plus soit révèle souvent même chose
comme ça arrive souvent oui on pouvait
le faire ça pouvait le récemment ça peut
nous arriver jusqu'à deux ou trois fois
ces mêmes
donc si si j'arrive à vous faire revenir
au public il faut que le gouvernement
vous garantissent que il va avoir des
horaires plus décent le plus normaux
ne faire revenir au public mois au
niveau du privé offre vraiment plus
offre des jeux souci je ne suis pas un
numéro je m'appelle martin au public on
me comté on me considère comme un être
humain et non comme un numéro s'il ya un
changement à farnham ont horreur on me
consulte on ne fait pas juste de changer
c'est arrivé plusieurs fois où mon
horaire changé dans la même semaine si
un moment donné à bord une stabilité
c'est celle pour le zinc le viendrait de
n'importe qui donc le gouvernement le
goût du travail à faire pour faire
revenir des infirmières au public je
vous écoute puis il faut froch il faut
qu'ils ajoutent des choses sur la table
pas mal il ya du chemin notch marque ou
est-ce que vous l'exclu et où vous êtes
et je les laissais aller puis peut-être
qu'ils vont aller me chercher monnaie
est pour l'instant où que je suis au
privé je suis vraiment bien j'ai j'ai
tout ce que j'ai de besoin donc ces
sources
moi ça va être difficile de retourner au
public
bonchamp parce que vous comprenez que
pour l'ensemble la société pilos pas
vous a payé le prix de sa mais on peut
pas se permettre de manquer 4300
infirmières dans le réseau public
c est de pire en pire
tout ce que vous êtes vous auriez envie
de me dire ça fait des années que les
infirmières le 10 à plus de bon sens ça
allait arriver là c'est andrée plus les
années avancent et plus que c'était
prévisible qui c'est sûr qu'avec la
copie de la pandémie mais ça a donné un
coup de hache dans les halls a senti le
colis faux bond bien espérons qui est
quand même des solutions pour quand même
attirer des gens dans le secteur public
martine bouchet merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé j'étais infirmière pendant
sept ans d'hôpital le gardeur et vous
êtes maintenant
infirmière dans le privé merci au revoir
merci bonsoir